eu sou desenvolvedor de rádio pessoal
estudante de psicologia
eu tinha feito uma trajetória de
projetos envolvendo a cidade de pau pra
educação saúde
a agenda do evento eu queria trazer um
dos maiores aprendizados produtivo
nacional principalmente aqueles que se
referem a seguinte também com a
tecnologia ela pode nos ajudar a
melhorar a educação do futuro é uma
pergunta bastante profunda tem conversa
mas eu quero trazer algumas respostas
mais interessantes que eu venho buscando
pra só que a boca para responder essa
pergunta ela taxa de uma história na
faculdade de psicologia 3 vários
estágios e necessários
eu conheci diversas escolas aqui na
nossa cidade com esse alunos alunas
professoras assistir a aulas
sai cada dia e passada não foi detectado
uma espécie de padrão tão diversos
problemas ou demandas é muito similares
entre todas aquelas escolas coisas que
vocês já devem saber por exemplo alunos
motivados ou com problemas de atenção o
mesmo desempenho os desiguais entre as
turmas
o hotel que as crianças inocentes que
parecem não se enquadrar no nosso tempo
pessoal
refletindo sobre isso eu me dei conta
cada vez mais de que esse não era isso
não é uma insistência isoladas aquelas
escolas
assim eram dificuldades e pontos a
melhorar o nosso sistema educacional um
todo que sendo padronizado reproduzir
seus problemas diversos
esse é o seguinte à eleição
existem maneiras de expandir a gente
melhorar o nosso sistema educacional
ponton foi justamente quando estava
pensando sobre isso na minha formação em
psicologia eu aprendi um dos conceitos
mais importantes da informação
ao mesmo tempo assim mais simples mas um
dos mais importantes da minha vida
ele se refere como motivação funciona no
cérebro humano é uma motivação
ela tem como origem no latim modelo que
significa movimento no programa
isso porque todo o movimento precisa de
um ponto de partida e um ponto de
chegada ea motivação é justamente aquela
força que nos movimenta de um pouco até
hoje mas é o mais interessante desse
conceito é que o nosso cérebro humano é
extremamente importante que a gente tem
esse ponto de chegada bem definido como
metas alcançar mais por exemplo porque
assim a gente saiba para onde quer se
locomover
quem sabe nosso ponto de chegada e
quando a gente consegue se motivar
dia após dia se movimentando nesse ponto
se a gente fosse aplicar esse conceito
com o nosso sistema educacional é a
gente já conhece as dificuldades e os
pontos a melhorar nosso sistema
educacional pensar em sair como
exatamente quer ver a educação daqui a
cinco 10 15 anos a gente pára para
pensar em como exatamente o nosso ponto
de chegada e poderia estar nos malditos
hoje para chegar
e foi justamente para tentar ajudar
nessa questão que eu participei de um
projeto chamado amp após ser uma
realidade do top a nossa proposta é
justo apresentação do seu mais sentido
hoje de maneira a gente pudesse
experience a esse nosso ponto de chegar
só que pra começar a projetar esse todo
ano eu precisei premiando a uma busca no
passado voltar um pouco no tempo
acontece que estudamos uma história da
educação mais mais aproveitando conta de
que a educação parece que não gostou
tanto com a evolução tecnológica quanto
outras áreas da sociedade
e eu digo isso porque hoje a gente
percebe alguns sistemas educacionais
metodologias conteúdos e das estruturas
físicas
muitos cenários naquela usados a 200 300
nosso abraço na adaptação mas chegando
mais próximo do presente
a contenção nas áreas adjacentes da
educação como tecnologia da informação
um deles é ascensão das plataformas
digitais de ensino que nos permite
procurar conteúdos através de vídeos
textos podcast lucas comunidades online
de bate-papo é importante mas é o mais
interessante dessa evolução tecnológica
ela não é só uma evolução tecnológica e
educação
mas ela também nos promove uma certa
mudança de marca
a maneira como a gente pensa maneira
como funciona porque já no presente
a gente não precisa mais ser somente
alunos ou alunas passivos de um sistema
educacional círculos é imposto
nossa formação através de vídeos preços
altos
buscando conteúdo o que a gente quiser
através das mídias que a gente preferiu
seguir no nosso próprio de aprendizagem
nos tornando assim aprendizes dons da
nossa própria aprendizagem
essa mudança de max mas ainda assim
esses exemplos refere o presente da
educação para poder projetar o futuro
possível provocação a gente usa uma
tecnologia um pouco mais recente no caso
seria verdade bertó são aqueles jogos
que você se torna também dança e ele
está com toda sua visão de maneira que
vocês pudessem visitar o ambiente ser
fácil
é como se ele estivesse vendo filmes
animações nos celulares ou uma televisão
só que com as reformas e finalmente
entra dentro desse clima de animação e
no nosso projecto numa sala a gente
colocou a pessoa com óculos realidade
virtual para visitar diversos ambientes
econômicos para a história da educação
enquanto isso ela ouvir uma narração que
falam sobre a evolução tecnológica dando
a clickon industrial digital e assim por
diante
durante suas portas de estímulos alguns
focos de atenção ou puxando atenção dela
para poder visualizar o conteúdo que ela
está ouvindo e visitamos e ainda por
trás disso existe uma trilha sonora que
denota apontou um nacional dessa
experiência fazendo com que seja
exatamente isso uma experiência de
aprendizagem mas um conteúdo que a
pessoa possa ter lido ou visto na
memória a memória vivida com qualquer
outra mas uma completamente projetada
para nos ensinar o conteúdo do projeto
dela fechada e foi bem legal disponível
gratuitamente na internet hoje eu quero
compartilhar com vocês uma coisa o
aprendizado mais legal de todo esse
projeto não se refere a essa hora de
produzir pra gente poder abrir nossos
olhos e enxergar tudo aquilo que a gente
ainda no mesmo as tecnologias porque de
uns anos pra cá indivíduos organizações
e empresas usavam verdade pau pra fazer
num medo domina na temática livre até
mesmo ao dólar a subir antes devido às
importantes como essa tecnologia já é
possível fazer toda semana de alça e
ainda assim todas as mudanças dentro de
si refere uma realidade virtual pode nos
ajudar na aplicação do soro
a gente tem que lembrar que vão
desenvolver conjuntamente diversas
outras tecnologias como realidade
aumentada e inteligência social internet
das coisas com lógica que dentro dessa
importante então ele consegue afirmar
que existe uma infinidade de futuros
possíveis para a educação
cada um de nós pudesse projetar e usar
isso vamos continuar hoje
então falou sobre o futuro sobre novas
tecnologias
as pessoas estão tendo uma visão de
futuro bastante otimista mas com o
passar do tempo eu venho escutando eu
gosto de acreditar
eu tenho uma visão do futuro projetista
porque o futuro não ser aquela coisa
distante difusa que a gente pára para
pensar no mesmo ano mas sim um projeto
cada um de nós pode tratar o futuro da
educação como um projeto que a gente
possa visualizar como a de educação
daqui a cinco 10 15 anos e usar essa
projeção futura para nos motivar hoje
como ponto de chegada
e assim a gente possa buscar de novo
a construção do futuro dia após dia por
dia assim
somente assim o roberto que a gente vai
chegar em 2030 por exemplo esses futuros
poderão se tornar realidade
o mais interessante é que todo esse
movimento frente a essa mudança
ele começa a parecer fácil uma simples
pergunta é como a tecnologia pode nos
ajudar a melhorar a educação do sul
eu sou bem o pequeno parte das respostas
vocês nessa briga
[Aplausos]